that was something that we did not visit
that shot i was trying to make sense of
how we could do this i don't know why in
our heads we couldn't see it yet that is
the most satisfying thing when he goes
out that window for the first time what
did you guys actually do on set and how
did you even get to creating these
scenes in the first place
today's episode is brought to you by
raycon stick around to the end to see
how you can get up to 20 off your
purchase of premium wireless earbuds hey
everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntman react i'm here with
our friends chris cohen and young lee
and the loyal boys this will be a good
episode growing up as a filmmaker here
in los angeles these two guys were doing
it alongside us but in their own realm
and just recently the movie shanghai
dropped they're both action designers on
the film it just makes me really
incredibly proud you know what i'm gonna
let them do their own introductions hey
what's going on guys i'm chris cowan you
guys may have seen me on one of the
episodes forever ago but i'm back i'm
hyped my inspiration is like very much a
lot of eastern works kung fu anime and
the fact that i got to work on shanghai
where you know that's something that i'm
just super passionate about is nuts uh
hey guys i'm young lee i am you know
the same as chris
that i'm super inspired by anime video
games comic books and it's just such an
honor to work on shanghai it changed my
life literally i'm actually a little
nervous because these guys have like
just accomplished so many amazing things
and are so good at what they do i can't
wait to hear you guys talk about all
your insights as we take a look at some
of these clips
you have the wrong guy does he look like
he can fight come on bro
this one-inch punch was something that
brad came to me for and he said he just
wanted some sort of stylized moment for
his first attack i mean it's not
technically a one-inch punch he travels
a good fight
right whatever
but that's what i loved about it because
chongqi's character is so much inspired
by bruce lee that for the first scene
that you see him fighting that's the
first move that he does it's like
perfect homage storytelling inspiration
but not being a complete rip chris that
was his thing that he wanted the fist to
come towards camera and in that split
second it emphasizes the speed in which
this all happens so this is the insert
shot saying the hand is coming at you
fast fast yeah and it sells that impact
so much harder yeah
homageness
he puts his jacket back on so the jacket
thing was from brad really who wanted to
pay homage to jackie and that was like
one of the hardest choreo beats to come
up with andy chang guillermo grissol and
pong jiang did a lot of the choreo for
this andy was jackie chan's stunt team
guillermo griswold we've done all the
kingsman movies with pungjong he did way
back in the day kick ass and scott
pilgrim and oh wow yeah and so like this
whole jacket choreo actually came from a
combination of all three of their
versions of the jacket gag that i cut
together to make
sense of that we're not imitating jackie
it's still a shanghi moment but you know
something new inspired by for sure
this bit was cool yeah
i think we did that on the day you see
who actually does that move yes yes wow
what was siemu's background he must have
some stunt work in his he had yeah he
had done some uh some stunt work up in
canada back in toronto
a bit that uh one of our performers
jesse turner came up with
he was our parkour specialist that's the
thing that we've learned to do on our
team is to lean on the experts for like
doing what they do best one thing i've
seen a lot of people say is like how a
lot of things are done right in this
movie like the martial arts were filmed
correctly i could see what was going on
it's edited correctly it was exciting
the story during the fights was done
correctly in other words the experts
were allowed to do their jobs and were
relied upon to bring something special
to those scenes we're only as good as
they allow us to be you can bring on the
best talent but if you don't allow them
to do what they do
then you might not get the best results
[Music]
i saw this clip on your instagram
yeah it's a really cool shot i also
cannot believe that this is all on a
blue screen
it looks so insane that's a huge bust
gimbal like 15 feet in the air by the
way it was like a theme park ride it was
cool
what's the secret to a good pose funny
enough we were working on that for the
longest longest yeah we tried so many
different things like whether it's claw
whether you tried a lot
yeah i remember there was one donnie in
shot that he was influenced by i think
it was out of kung fu jungle but to say
that it was influenced by donnie i mean
obviously donnie's influenced by other
gender so
i mean it gets lost
that is the most satisfying thing when
he goes out that window for the first
time yeah it's something about the
visual effects shot as well as just the
sound of the glass break
yeah that shift in the lighting sets the
tone for oh okay now something's right
it's about to go down yeah and this is
like paying homage to old boy right
dustin wanted an old boy shot at the end
of this and just holding this shot it's
just so satisfying to hold shots with
the bus sequence being so chaotic to
have a clean moment where you don't cut
away i think it's really refreshing and
it changes the whole vibe of the scene
[Music]
are you on camera for most of these
shots all the good ones
for the bus i did a lot this movie was
there was a lot of work there was so
chris usually does most of the camera
but he's busy making other scenes while
we're shooting right sometimes i'm in
the sun station pre-vision yeah the
scope of what we were doing was so big
that's why we had such a big stunt team
and we had a lot of fight coordinators
and we had two other action designers it
really helped change the vibe of all the
everything had its own yeah flavor
[Music]
[Applause]
what was difficult for me coming onto
this project is that a lot of the action
i'd done in the past had very much
japanese flair or kickboxing and i
hadn't had the chance to shoot a lot of
chinese martial arts when we started
shooting the visits i had a hard time
wrapping my mind around how to
photograph these shapes and the shapes
and body language is completely
different if you remember the last time
i was on here i just finished up the ua
project with gee yeah yeah you know i
was doing the grass shots for the ua and
i was like i wonder if i can sneak that
into shang somewhere like for a few
shots
there you go
right there yep that's yep i see it
that's your ua shower 100
it was really fun to work on this fight
in particular because it's different
from a lot of fights just in general and
that we had to tell a love story
throughout the sequence within their
movements and obviously both of the
actors and their stunt doubles they just
they brought it on this when i was
watching the uh the scene with my wife
at the end when one woo is fighting
chongqi and they're kind of recreating
this moment and shawn's like taking you
know inspiration from how his mother
fought like when's the flirty smiling
gonna start
[Laughter]
it's a different
shot actually i was trying to make sense
how are we gonna do this it was just one
of those shots where like i don't know
why in our heads we couldn't see it yet
we're both times this is how we're gonna
this is gonna do it it'll work
you know those moments when you're on
set where you're just trying to convince
yourself that it's gonna work yeah it
was like i hope the vfx team can figure
it out later right
yeah yeah it did work
i was surprised
hey if you're watching this video or the
series and you're not subscribed
consider doing so it really helps us out
helps other people discover the show so
yeah thanks
we've been talking a lot about these
scenes and what you guys think is cool
and how you know it works in your minds
but specifically what did you guys
actually do on set how did you guys
function and how did you even get to
creating these scenes in the first place
well both of us as action designers we
are sort of the filmmakers of the stunt
team our responsibility is to tell the
story
of the action sequence the first stage
that we go through is building vignettes
small clips highlights of what could be
for a character or for our power and
also helps us figure out the style of
filmmaking that we as best use for the
story from there we don't shoot out our
shots that we need that's also the time
to like explore stunt rig setups and
then we also get to film it and see like
okay what's the best way to film this
cool gag that we've come up with from
there once we've assembled it then we
have that presentation with the
directors and the producers and there's
a back and forth a conversation with the
director okay this is what i like about
the scene this is what i don't like i
will say he's definitely the most
annoying avenger to pre-visit for
like do you know how much easier it
would have been to just have a hammer
or a shield
like the fact that we had to like do all
these rings i was like oh yeah that was
yeah that was there was some points
where we got a little lazy and we just
like just imagine it yeah
it goes around them and
yeah after we've done back and forth to
go back we reshoot it's really all about
just refining the work honestly by the
time we're done with the busy games we
had like 70 versions of it that one was
the most difficult and this is before
you've actually filmed the bus right and
they're not always that extreme but like
the bus had so many moving parts that
you know this is the first time we're
seeing sean move and figure out what his
visual style is yeah you know what areas
of homage and inspiration are we gonna
find to create this character's moveset
so it was difficult so after all that
prep then we come in to shoot the actual
movie
so you shot the movie like about 20
times at this price all right i
practiced on the day i'm good to go yeah
and we've solved all the problems that
always come up when you're shooting
indie movies so all that you're really
focused on on the day is the story and
the performance but when we go to
production and we start shooting my role
shifts to an on-set editor and i'm
cutting and editing the film as chris is
normally shooting it and then see like
what works what doesn't or how can we
save the shot if we didn't have time i
was fortunate enough to shoot the
majority of the first sequence in tylo
with lee and win woo fighting towards
the back end of the film it was an
interesting process because we went
through obviously covet some of that had
you know brought on different people and
different crews and we had another very
talented camera operator come on and
join us on main unit and he shot the
majority of the father-son showdown
at that point i was fortunate enough to
have destin ask me if i would sit next
to him and help him direct that sequence
you know he gave us our own chairs
directing chairs put our names on it was
like oh man it's the little things i
tell you what
i thought it was very valuable
experience like sitting there and being
able to talk to another camera operator
about what you were looking for within
the viz and how we can bring that out on
the day there were a few specific shots
in here that i knew that i could at
least help speed up the day because i
had done them before and i knew they
could be a little tricky and one in
particular was the stitch shot we did a
stitch shot
boom
step step spin and kick when who holds
this and now launches right here is a
real performer and it stitches back into
cmu sliding back and that was something
that we did not visit that was something
that we pitched to them on the day
and that was nerve-wracking because i
was like instead of making these two
separate shots i feel like we could
combine them together and i pitched that
to the producer in destin and they were
like yeah if you think you can do it and
i was like yeah i think i can do it
[Laughter]
i didn't show them that eye move yeah
and yeah it blended really well
chris did a version of this whole viz
with toys by the way oh yeah he shot the
whole city with the
stanley action figure and captain
america
and like literally that was handed to
him by marvel
on a marvel movie it's like a marvel
movie that goes to show honestly like
even on the big budget movies like going
low budget is sometimes super helpful
yeah it's not always about like the big
like hollywood treatment you know what i
mean you know the thing that our fight
coordinators i have to give credit to
they're all like directors themselves
and they know how to shoot and edit and
having that like complete understanding
makes a huge difference when they talk
the same language as you the more
filmmakers that you have within your
stunt department i think the better
because your director and especially
your camera crews are going to be more
open to listening to your to your
feedback if you're more so just on the
side of choreography and and yeah just
stunts only the dp they're going to be
like okay we'll do what we do yes so
that's why you see a lot of like stunt
visitors from a lot of other movies that
just look nothing like the final movie
and that's where you have that
disconnect exactly i mean working on
shanghai kind of reminded why i love
filmmaking in the first place honestly
it reinvigorated my passion for film and
storytelling also because everybody
loved working on the film and wanted to
do such a good job like everyone was
there and super passionate and they
chose in the final product and that's
the thing with you know even with what
you guys do here everyone's passionate
about it everyone loves it and it
totally bleeds onto the screen the
audience feels that you can't shoot a
film and not care right that's so
important and if we get more sets like
that in this industry we're going to get
even better films
all right here's the deal okay i've been
asking all of the stunt performers who
come through the studio hey guys what is
the perfect pair of earbuds that you
wear for your lifestyle they're on set
they're training they're doing
everything else in between so they're
like jake guess what we have the perfect
earbud for you courtesy of today's
sponsor raycod with their new everyday
earbuds they offer an improved rubber
oil look and feel and optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit raycons also
offer eight hours of play time and a
32-hour battery life there's also a
built-in microphone so you can take
calls at the press of a button raycons
also start at half the price of other
premium brands but they sound just as
good and of course they come with a 45
day happiness guarantee so if you don't
like them guess what you just go ahead
and send them back maybe you get a
different pair i don't know but you got
45 days but seriously raycon they offer
an incredible product and they do so
with a consumer first mindset and that's
what we love about it over here so if
you guys are interested head on over to
buy raycon.com
coral crew and get up to 20 off your
purchase of raycons that's
byracon.com or crew or click the link in
the description below and you can get up
to 20 off plus exclusive offers anyways
now that you know what true hollywood
stunt performers are using to enhance
their lifestyle the decision is on you
so let's get back to the episode
i love some recommendations for good
gunfight films that pre-date the 2000s
and thank you to everybody for leaving
comments and suggestions they really
help us find awesome clips and really
enrich our knowledge of the history of
cinema it's been awesome we found so
many cool things due to your
recommendations so thank you i don't
know if you guys know this but we have a
website and we have extended episodes of
our react series on there so if you're
really into the show if you're a big fan
of it you're really going to enjoy the
extended episodes they're a lot of fun i
love that you guys did did that yeah get
the app guys get the app do it so much
missing it there's no ads too you can
watch everything with no ads but you
know what
we still love youtube too so we'll
always be here as well don't worry the
app
well this is
one of the most enjoyable sessions of uh
seven react we've ever filmed thanks for
joining us guys
yeah if you guys would like to check out
any of uh these guys's stuff you can
actually check out chris's youtube
channel there's a bunch of awesome
shorts including some pretty cool my
hero academia fan films river next three
i will have a link in the description
below young he has an instagram young
and the dangerous but other than that
they're just here to chill and this is
awesome thanks for watching consider
subscribing if you haven't go watch
chongqi in theaters yes oh wait by the
time this comes out it's out of theaters
it'll still be in theaters wouldn't it
maybe
october or oh maybe like some dollar
theater or watch it on disney flash